right now I am in sauce face Switzerland
staying in a apartment
my wife is attending European graduate
school and so I've got a little bit of
vacation time although I'm doing a lot
of work right now and I thought I would
get caught up on some of the backlog of
questions that need to be answered from
the Q&A video if you if you want to ask
any questions by the way ask them not on
this one as a comment but on the the one
that I've linked to in the description
so I've got 10 more philosophy related
questions lined up and here they go
and remove the red has an interesting
question about the history of ideas for
a period of time in the Middle Ages
Aristotle was revered as the philosopher
yet over the last several centuries and
today that reverence returned to Plato
how and why did Aristotle's prominence
change over time so this is a there's a
big complicated story to tell here I'm
going to just sort of hit on some of the
main points working our way backwards
you know Aristotle and Plato are focused
on and read and revered about the same
today at least by people who do you know
any sort of historically connected or
founded philosophy I wouldn't say that
that Plato has a prominence over him now
and I wouldn't actually say that after
the eclipses of Aristotle in the late
Middle Ages and the early modern period
that they were turning to Plato if you
if you look at who people were actually
citing and and you know drawing on
interestingly enough if he wanted to
pick an ancient philosopher who was
given a much higher status than Plato or
Aristotle in the modern period it would
be Cicero you can see this especially in
David Hume who loves quoting Cicero at
length and actually ends up modeling
some of his works after some of Cicero's
works living the dialogues of natural
religion now Aristotle took a while to
catch on in the Middle Ages they hand
some of his tax available mainly through
through commentaries and then you know
suddenly they're available in the High
Middle Ages and then there's this
question what do we do with this guy and
there they were all over the map there's
some people who totally rejected
Aristotle there are other people who are
like you know Aristotle all the way the
avarice and then there were people in
the middle like Thomas Aquinas
he was seen as the philosopher because
he provided the most systematic way of
approaching things once he actually had
you know a good portion of his his texts
why did that that wane well you know
there there was too much fundamentalism
of Aristotle's works meaning that people
weren't really thinking through them but
they would just cite Aristotle and this
was one of the problems with with late
not middle or early late scholasticism
Harold sward has an unanswerable
question for me who would you consider
the greatest philosopher of all time by
the profundity of their ideas the
clarity the rigor of their arguments
clarity and honesty by which they
present their ideas and the influence
they've had those are a lot of criteria
it might be possible it might be
possible to answer with respect to one
of those criteria but even thinking
about the influence that that a
philosopher has had you know I mean who
would we place in those those realms if
we want to think about this historically
Plato Aristotle Augustine Cicero Aquinas
Descartes Locke I mean they're all you
know they're all great contenders for
that can't haggle you know Nietzsche I
don't know who do I consider the
greatest philosopher of time I don't I
don't have a good answer to that because
and you can see this in my work I don't
focus just on one guy and torn in a
whole bunch of different directions
there are some things that I really love
in Plato although I don't do a lot of
writing on him at this point a lot of
things I love in Aristotle I do do a lot
of writing on him I really like Cicero I
think he's under undervalued stocks so
to speak because he provides us with you
know interesting presentations of the
big heavy hitters of the ancient period
I mean if we if we fast forward over the
the medievals which would be a big
mistake but you know got to keep this
short if we had to pick like of the
modern times that's hard for me to say I
mean you know that I love Hegel although
I'm not a galleon but you know there's
some other great systemic philosophers
you know to phenomenologist come to mind
in particular Mach Schaller and dietrich
von Hildebrand I also you know really
like Maurice bloomed out for that sort
of thing as well and I think part of
what I would I really admire in a
philosopher is there bill
to take in other people's perspectives
and consider them and make them in a
certain part their own
that's what dialectics is really about
you know the best contemporary
practitioner that would be Alistair
McIntyre
so Christopher Dunn has a question could
there be a berkeley in metaphysics
without God and the the simple answer is
no and no for two different reasons one
is it wouldn't be Berkeley on
metaphysics in a sort of trivial way
because Berkeley has God in there right
and and so if you're gonna take out you
know an integral part of the system it's
no longer what what he intended but you
could ask you know that question another
way and say okay I understand that that
Berkeley historically actually did he
have God as you know central in that but
what if we adopt his perspective on
things and then we decide to see if we
can you know retain what's what's really
valuable in the system while taking God
out of the system altogether and again
the answer to that would be no and it
wouldn't cease being our Klien in that
trivial sense the whole system would
fall apart and here's here's why God is
God is required in order to hold the
entire system of phenomena together this
is this is why Berkeley you know in a
certain respect prefigures some some
very interesting you know notions about
certainty and you know the ability to to
have something that goes beyond just
sort of public agreement or perception
the thing is in Barkley's metaphysics we
have we have things that appear to us
and and they don't have manner
they they are phenomena and then there
are spirits which are something that is
not simply reducible to the phenomena
and we are we are that where perceivers
and then there there has to be something
to hold everything together because you
know think of it sort of like if
everything is really perception then
you're just sort of surrounded by it you
know this penumbra of what it is that
you're perceiving and as soon as you
quit
receiving it no longer in any functional
way exists and the only way to hold it
together then is to have a whole bunch
of other people sort of agreeing with
each other with overlapping bands of
perception but then you know how do you
know that what they're doing is is
actually on track maybe they're you know
totally deceived about things God is the
centerpiece for Berkeley that's part of
why he was you know making the arguments
that he was
giggy's 78 says the universe is
limitless men are limited therefore
there is no way to know the ultimate
truth of the universe do you agree no
and I've got a couple reasons you know
there is first one thing we ought to
point out there's different types of
limitlessness and if we're thinking
merely in terms of you know like a
mathematical plenum and mathematical
infinity yeah sure that's fine but that
doesn't mean that we're not able to
generalize because once you've got you
know the general ideas down you can
apply them successfully you can say well
I don't know what the hell is going on
way over there and I never will cuz I
could never reach that point but we
write a actually get there it would it
would have to conform to these sorts of
you know laws or principles or whatever
and so you know if you're thinking of
limitlessness in a purely you know
arithmetic GM geometry geometrical
mathematical way then that's not an
issue if on the other hand you're
thinking beyond that you say well you
know there could always be things that
we don't actually know and we can't
possibly know them then the you know I
would actually take a fairly pragmatic
approach to this and say well if they
really impact what we know about things
you know then we'd actually know about
them they'd have some sort of effect in
our existence that we could maybe figure
out if not then we you know we have
other again we can like focus on the
general things it really also depends on
what you are calling the ultimate truth
of the universe so if you're gonna talk
about the ultimate truth of the universe
I don't know how you do that without
thinking in terms of you know either
like a world system or general
principles and it seems like we could
come to know them it could be very
difficult it might require generations
to do that but I don't see why we would
be necessarily cut off from it just by
being finite
Rob Kenneth asks do you think that Hans
yonas his critique of ethics and
religious belief after world war 2 is
still relevant now his discussion of the
responsibilities to society of
technology creators and users now
yonis is not somebody who I know an
awful lot about I certainly haven't read
you know my way through all of his works
the one that I've spent the most time on
is the Gnostic religion because I found
it very useful and thought-provoking
when I used to teach classes having to
do with with the canonical and
non-canonical Gospels so you know yet
you take this with it with a grain of
salt all right I'm not I'm Eddie
yonas scholar I understand some of the
basic ideas and so as critique of ethics
and religious belief you know I'm not
even quite sure what what all that means
so I can't comment than that but what
about his discussion of the
responsibilities of society it's a
society of technology creators and users
could that I understand a bit better and
he's got this this principle or
imperative that we should always act in
such a way as to how does he put it
there we go so that the effects of your
action are compatible with the
permanence of genuine human life that
you know that makes a lot of sense I
don't think that he is doing something
completely original and saying that I
think that you can find I think you can
call that out of college you can also
call that out of Aristotle you could
call that out of Augustine you can call
that out of a lot of moral theorists
it's something that makes a lot of sense
nowadays we might think of that in terms
of this umbrella term of sustainability
which is a very nebulous term that
requires some clarification but one part
of sustainability is this notion that we
do have some weak there are some sort of
responsibility to not leave things
totally screwed up people that come
after us so we should be thinking
about the effects of our technology
think of the the concommittant ovens
here's a question from mark Schmitt can
you elaborate on the different
categories aristotle proposes for
example genus as to what they refer to
so genus isn't a category the category
is properly you know you're in the
proper sense are the predicable the
things that can be said about about
something and Aristotle gives you a list
of them and in the metaphysics by the
way he actually there's a priority of
them as well you know in the categories
you just get substance Lucia and then
these other you know categories as well
and he spent some time discussing them
but he doesn't lay out a sort of
priority of them but in the metaphysics
its substance quality the Pollan and
number or quantity and then the other
ones that require involved and these are
not meant to be used in a sort of
schematic deductive way it's supposed to
be something that we can use so that we
can understand how we need to
distinguish between things so he might
for example say good is said in many in
many ways and so good can be you know in
terms of equality it can be in terms of
place it could be in terms of action or
suffering it's good qua this now genus
species differentiy all these sorts of
things those are also discussed in in
these logical works of Aristotle and and
they're you know they're classes of
things that you can put things into
Arizona believes that that in some way
they exist in the particulars of course
so I man right I'm looking at me right
now also male also 44 year old man and
then we're getting more and more
specific right more and more about the
species but there's other 44 year old
men out there
so I don't know if this helps up much
but what can you do in two minutes
mark Schmitt also asks could you please
explain the distinction between
universals and particulars and I'm going
to assume that he means it because the
context of the other questions in an
Aristotelian sense because you know
there's there's different metaphysics
out there and a metaphysics is connected
with with a logic a logos you know a way
of understanding the connections between
things or you know realities words or
discourse and thought actually a full
logic has to extend to action and
willing as well but that's like that's a
complicated issue
so universals and particulars Aristotle
thinks that universals don't strictly
speaking exist or have being in the way
that you know real things do so again
I'll use myself as an example human
being on purpose right that exists in me
it's what makes me what I am and it's a
class that we can include you in
assuming your human being watching this
and all the all the other human beings
that have existed or happen to you know
are yet to come so long as they fit into
a certain set of criteria have a certain
form a certain you know structure they
are human beings and they are individual
human beings very often when we're
talking about particulars we mean
individuals universal in particular can
in fact the relational terms if we're
talking about you know being more
particularly more universal because we
can have larger and larger categories or
groupings that we use classes but
Aristotle thinks that that this is part
of what we're you know when you see me
as man you're perceiving the universal
in the particular and your mind is
taking in that universal and it
certainly exists in your
so this is an interesting question to
ask by biggie 78 I believe that we
humans must teach the new generations
two subjects critical thinking and basic
research skills do I agree uh yes I
would not say those are the only two
fundamental skills that we need to teach
them but I certainly think that those
are among the ones that are much more
sorely needed and are not being supplied
adequately I think that we want to have
not just you know vague claims about you
know that we're doing critical thinking
critical thinking this is you know if I
want to get on my soapbox critical
thinking is one of those things which
actually does have a rigorous definition
the different parts of it have been laid
out for a long time and yet we have all
these Yahoo's saying I'm teaching
critical thinking in my classes and you
ask them what do you mean by critical
thinking and if it's some vague thing or
it's well I'm teaching people to
question something that's not yet
critical thinking you know what for
example one of the components of
critical thinking is being able to make
arguments and being able to strengthen
arguments being able to analyze other
people's arguments is another one being
able to actually diagram an argument is
a critical thinking skill I think we
ought to be teaching that and not
leaving it up to the people that are
currently teaching I think we ought to
be teaching that K through 12 I think
that it should be part of it and basic
research skills very important in this
internet age where the immediate go-to
for most people is as Wikipedia or
sparknotes or something like that now
I'm not saying Wikipedia is you know
wrong matter fact it's gotten a lot
better but that isn't where you ought to
be going that research means actually
going to as close to the sources as you
can get and we need to teach people how
to be able to do that how to evaluate
those I do think there's a lot of other
things that we need as well but those
you know if we actually got on the ball
with with those two skills that would be
that would produce a
it's social changes
so Connor Saira Saira whit's if I
mispronounced your name I'm sorry says
I've been seeing some philosophical
fields such as new materialism and
speculative realism which seemed to
bring Continental sensibilities to
subjects which have been overlooked by
continental thought what are your
general thoughts in these two fields and
where do you see the meting in the
future so I don't know much about them
you know I had to actually google this
and see what's meant by these because
whenever you use words like materialism
or realism or speculative in the history
of philosophy these might immense a ton
of different things and people love to
coin new terms for what it is that
they're doing don't you see if they
catch on or not so as far as I
understand yeah they are Continental
sensibilities that they're drawing on
some of them are drawing on some
continental thinkers like God you seems
like I'll to ther would be somebody that
they'd be interested in as well have
these areas been overlooked by by
continental thought only if we define
continental thought pretty narrowly and
I'm a big enemy of that if your
definition of continental thought leaves
out for example Maurice blowing no blow
now or Gabrielle Marcel or Dietrich von
Hildebrand or you know all were gets you
know cited but not looked at very
closely then I don't not very you know
interested that's why I don't give much
credence to the analytic continental
split because they're so you know small
I think that you know when it comes to
these these issues of like epistemology
and how should we should understand the
universe and how things come together
I think Continentals have been talking
about that I think that they've been
focused a lot more on on social reality
to fine
where is this stuff going I don't know I
don't know enough about about the
thinkers that are you know at the center
of what looks like it could be a
movement to really have much of an
informed opinion and since I don't have
an informed opinion and probably
shouldn't have too much of an opinion
this is a really tough question by Marx
met one that I have to admit I don't
have an answer for all right because
I've got too many answers what is your
favorite non philosophical book and why
do you enjoy it so I have you know I've
thought about this a number of different
times since being asked this question
what is my favorite non philosophical
book and I can land on ones that I
particularly like but they're not my
favorite in the sense that they're above
all the others I can tell you about the
stuff I like to to read that's not
directly philosophical but some often
times has a lot of philosophy in it I
have a real interest in some of these
20th century British writers who often
are you know struggling with their
religious sensibilities like Graham
Greene
evylyn wah Irish Murdock I would
actually like you know be willing to
migrate Flannery O'Connor in there
there's a depth to their for their
thought and there are the writings and a
receptiveness to being able to sort of
let the characters do what they're gonna
do and not try to you know dogma ties
about it that I really I really love
about their works I also really like you
know science fiction and there are some
authors that I will go back to the rest
of my life and they tend to be of two
sorts no three sorts really one would be
the just absolutely brilliant great
storytelling but very philosophical
writers like philip k dick and a that
void you know there's some others that
could fit in there you know Roger
Zelazny with the amber chronicles
because you know the world of amber is
essentially a neo plate was construct
and things like that and then I really
also do like the
it's called the new new wave of science
fiction it's pretty old came about in
the 60s and 70s and I mentioned Zelazny
Moorcock farmer the green people like
that and then I like the the sort of
world designer you know a million
different plots going on at the same
time people like George are Martin you
know with the Game of Thrones supposed
to be seven books it's he's up to book
five the dune early doing stuff is
really good for the same sorts of
reasons
who else would fall into that category I
don't know another another author I
realize I'm going way past the to two
minute mark with this to him you notice
that talking about books you can go on
forever another author who I really
really love and I'm almost you know
attempted to learn Spanish just than the
original would be Jorge Lee for Hayes
but again you know a lot of
philosophical themes a lot of playing
with philosophy going out of his works
so I've already gone on quite quite too
long with this and making an exception
in this case but I should cut this short
now and so I'll just leave it at that